hey guys Pete here this will be my
Westworld season 3 episode 7 preview
slash trailer breakdown episode 6 was a
pretty good one probably my favorite of
the season so far and it was strange
that there was a lot in that trailer
that didn't end up being in that episode
we'll talk about that in a bit but first
your spoiler warning this video will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in West world through the sixth
episode of season three I'll also be
speculating on future events so if
you're not caught up or if you want to
go in cold then now's the time to leave
episode seven is titled past Pollan it's
a chess reference
I don't play so my knowledge of this
only goes as far as reading the wiki
page basically a passed pawn is a
situation where the pawn which is
generally the weakest piece can gain a
lot of strength in the endgame if you
can move it past your opponent's
defenses it can be promoted on the other
end of the board so it goes from being a
weak piece to any piece you want it to
be usually a queen one of the things I
liked about episode six besides the man
in black therapy session was that they
gave an explanation for why Mei would go
against Dolores or at least appear to be
going against her from the early
trailers they've been hinting at to
showdown and we've had this shot of
Maeve approaching with the katana but it
was difficult to understand why maid
might fight for Sarah now we know she
really doesn't have a choice in the
matter
and that Dolores has taken all of this
into account when making her plans
Maeve's body has been rebuilt and we
last saw her waiting for another host
body to finish printing at the dulles
headquarters this is most likely
Clementine since we know that she's one
of those hosts that were being printed
people have been collecting shots of
host IDs when they come up and
clementines matches one of the ones we
saw in this shot so maybes coming out
and she's got some old friends with her
Bernard and Stubbs are with the man in
black or should I say the man in white
char Loras just lost the family she was
taking two and Ciroc and insight have
taken over Delos things are starting to
take shape and they should be there only
two episodes left in the season and
quite possibly in the series let's look
at the trailer scene by scene and then
I'll talk about where I think things are
headed the trailer opens with the shot
of a satellite in orbit
we see it open up and something Falls
from it and this is probably a kinetic
weapon it could be a missile since as of
right now kinetic bombardment is
hypothetical but it's something that
could very well exist in the future when
Westworld takes place when I first saw
this I thought about Ciroc making the
comment about retasking all the
corporate satellites to the park in the
last episode I was thinking we could be
seeing the beginning of the end for West
world and the other parks that still
could be the case but there's something
that happens later in this trailer that
probably makes more sense and voiceover
we hear an unknown woman probably
Caleb's therapist saying start at the
beginning then we see a shot of him
running through some brush it looks like
this is from his time in the military
and we'll see some more of that as we go
next we see Caleb with longer hair
taking a limbic tab wearing civilian
clothes and this shot he looks like he's
in a city setting likely back at home
rather than out in the field and that's
followed by a close-up of him taking a
tab in a similar shot but it could be
happening somewhere else like it's just
showing that he was taking these things
for awhile that cuts to him in full
combat gear taking a tab we can see his
uniform has his last name on it and he's
in the US Army we hear him say I'm
having a hard time remembering and then
we see his friend Francis smiling in his
army uniform we see that they're
together and caleb is smiling too he
flips his guns magazine in the air and
catches it the next shot looks like it's
him being blown back by an explosion or
some kind of impact we see leaves in the
air as he falls back out of the frame
that cuts to what looks like a military
command center we see a man in the
uniform with a headset on from behind
and then the voice over we hear Nichols
comma Caleb I think it's this guy saying
it but the voiceover and this trailer is
a little difficult to track there's an
out-of-focus map on a large display in
front of him and if I had to guess I
would say it's a city he's looking at
you can't really make anything out
though next there's a shot of Caleb with
a shaved head and civilian clothes
walking away from a city it's not clear
where this is it looks like it could be
in the Middle East maybe by the
architecture what's really interesting
about the sequences that
you watch it frame by frame you see a
projectile comes down behind him and
just before the cut you see the impact
this is probably related to that
satellite from the beginning but as
mentioned it could be Ciroc destroying
the Parkes that cuts to a shot of him in
his military gear he's looking through
the scope of a rifle he's next to a
vehicle using it as a shield and then we
see him take a shot the shot of caleb
firing the rifle cuts to someone getting
shot later in the trailer will realize
that this is him shooting this guy based
on what we can see in the background
this guy is getting shot in the US we
could see American flags in the classic
Corvette next to him looks like it has a
Wyoming license plate he's wearing
tactical gear and he's well-armed and it
looks like he's the last man standing we
see other guys in similar clothes laying
around on the ground where they're
already shot and when we see it in the
longer shot it looks like the building
could be a bank and this could be a
robbery that's gone wrong but that
doesn't really make sense of why the
military would be there but there's also
this celebration going on outside of
this building so it's hard to say why
caleb is picking people off in his
military gear this shot that cuts to a
shot of Caleb and probably Francis it's
in silhouette so you can't tell but I
don't know who else he would be with
they're leading a hooded prisoner and we
can see that the guy has zip tie cuffs
on after that we see them in the
military medical area caleb is sitting
in a chair he leans forward and we can
see that he has a gunshot flesh wound on
his head I'm guessing this is what he
was referring to in Episode one when he
was talking to the Ricoh courier he
mentioned that he had been shot in the
head before we see them in an urban
setting walking up a set of stairs
they're wearing masks and they're
pulling out their guns and the voiceover
we hear Barnard say outliers and as they
approach this building we can see the
name
it's the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion and
that is in Los Angeles so they're on
American soil and it doesn't seem to be
a military operation it cuts to a
close-up shot of Caleb and we get a
better look at the mask as he fires a
shot see these eyeballs on there I'm not
sure if that's just for decoration or if
those are supposed to do something it
looks like they're just printed that way
to be scary or something along those
lines after that we see Dolores running
there's an explosion or some sort of
impact
and we see debris falling from above her
then we get a shot of Maeve in this cool
new black suit making a maneuver we here
say you've turned a young man before and
we see that she has a drone firing at
her she's running with the katana in her
hand
she sort of dives and does a roll and at
least for now she looks like she's fully
capable of evading this thing what she
says you've turned a young man before
that sounds to me like she's probably
talking to Dolores about Caleb turning a
young man before brings up thoughts of
William when he first came to the park
we only get a little bit more of their
conversation so it's definitely too
early to tell but that's what I'm
guessing and we don't see her companions
here they're off-screen I guess or
they've split up I said Clementine is
probably one of them Hector was one of
these codes of course his pearl got
crushed so he won't be there and my
guess for the other one would have been
armistice but I was reading an article
that Joanna Robinson wrote and she
mentioned that the actress that played
Shogun world's version of Armistice Hana
Rio if I'm saying that right that actor
made an appearance at the season three
premiere so she's probably more likely
but either way we don't see her
companions here then we get a shot of
Bernard looking at a monitor with
Williams picture on it in the picture
he's wearing his man in white outfit
from the previous episode and the status
on his profile says he's deceased I'm
guessing they're just faking his death
here probably just making it look like
he's dead because he'd be harder to
track that way and it doesn't make sense
for them to kill him off right here and
there's also the fact that Bernard turns
to him and he appears to be standing
right there there could be some editing
trickery but then faking his death makes
much more sense given what happened the
last episode I'm guessing that part of
this episode's going to involve Bernard
and Stubbs breaking the man in white out
over that we hear a woman's voice say
tell me how you got here
and then we see Maeve talking to Dolores
and she says he can't save you now and
then right at the same time we hear a
man's voice say how did you get here Cal
we watch the lawyers struggling to get
away from her to me it looks like this
is right before Maeve catches up to her
and starts talking Delores his arm is
chopped off from above the elbow and it
feels pretty likely that Maven or katana
are
behind this injury that cuts to another
shot of the hooded prisoner as we hear
the woman's voice say start at the
beginning again so the training that
makes it feel like we're gonna be
getting this really long detailed
history of Caleb's life and how he lost
his memories and what those memories are
and how they affect him I'm not a
hundred percent sure that it'll be as a
substantial part of the upcoming episode
as this trailer makes it feel like I
mean we get another shot of him looking
through the scope of the rifle and we
see that mask guy getting shot again and
there's a shot of Francis and we hear
caleb say I've been here before
and that's overtop of a shot of him
holding a rifle and him running away
through the brush this time from behind
and while all of the stuff from his past
is interesting this is also the
penultimate episode of the season and
maybe the series so I feel like this
trailer is making it seem like we're
gonna spend a lot more time with Caleb's
history than we actually are either way
in the current timeline we see him
standing in front of a lot of equipment
it's not clear where this is but I feel
like this is tied to the closing shot of
the last trailer that we didn't see and
possibly those shots where Ciroc had a
gun to his head after the shot of him on
this platform we hear Dolores say spent
your whole life believing you're a
follower lead and we see those two
standing there Dolores is behind him
looking at him as the trailer closes so
Dolores seems to be using Caleb for
something that she can't do herself it
seems like his status as an outlier is
important and I'm curious as to what's
going on with all of that but there's
really not much in this trailer to tell
us I do believe like I said that last
shot of him is related to things that we
saw in the previous trailer after
watching that last trailer I thought
they were flying to Westworld
because we had that shot of the Mesa and
we had that shot of them on horseback
they could also have been headed to
Mexico to where Bernard and the man in
black are but the timelines a little bit
confusing things in Episode five and six
overlapped in the timeline we see his
therapist get the notification about the
data dump so we know how Dolores and
Caleb and the man in black and Bernards
stories are synced up and then we also
know about char Laura's and Maeve how
they're lined up
I'm not a hundred percent sure when
Maeve gets printed last we saw them
Caleb and Delores were flying somewhere
we know at some point Maeve and Delores
are gonna have a showdown in the city
and that they will end up in this
conversation that we see in this trailer
but I don't know for sure what the
sequence of all of it is I mean they
showed that picture of Delores and Teddy
riding on that Ridge right before they
showed Delores and Caleb riding horses
in what looked like the park so there
could still be going there and it could
just overlap with the events that we saw
happening at the delos headquarters one
thing that's really standing out to me
is that Delores has had two chances to
destroy Maeve's pearl and she didn't do
it like I said we got that idea that she
had taken into consideration what Ciroc
would do with Maeve when she made her
plans so to me it seems like she's
leaving may have Alive because it's
important to her plan much in the same
way she kept Bernhard alive I hope
that's the case and that really sounds
like there could be something
interesting that comes out of that but
I'm gonna end it there so let me know
what you think what do you think is
gonna happen in the next episode how do
you think things are playing out do you
think we're headed to a series finale do
you think they're going to end it after
this I know they've mentioned having
more seasons in mind but but it also
feels like we're moving towards a
conclusion I don't know they let me know
what you think please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'm
thinking about doing more Westworld
videos now that better call Saul is
gonna be wrapping up this week so make
sure you check back for that thanks for
watching
I'll talk to you soon